you
hi everyone it's Jerry I'm on Leech s
org and I just got paired up against a
familiar opponent we don't get to play
too many blitz games what do I want to
do against my buddy pehoe back here
let's throw the French defense Adam
that'll that'll toss them for a loop
there all right so this is a 3-2 and
should I go with a winner waar let's
give that a whirl why not and actually
I'm going to play it super positional on
Queen g4 I'm prepared to under develop
to defend my sensitive g7 point so my
intention is not to go in for this
damaging of the pond and that bishop for
night slash pawn structure imbalance but
rather this the trick here or my idea at
least is to exchange light square bishop
s' my bad guy for their good guy and one
day anchor a knight here with white
having a space advantage on the King
side I may very well opt to Castle
queenside I think this is a good move to
insert yes this night can be a great
bother I'm making a lot of pawn moves
and I am behind the development this can
certainly cost me but the position in
the center is closed and what more is
there to say I think this is a moment
for me to play Bishop to H Bishop to a6
or maybe even maybe even a 5 you know
they
weakened v4 with that move so this is
maybe not out of the question
Bishop to a6 you know what let's go
straight in for this why not you know I
was going to I was going to delay this
Bishop move delay this development and
basically wait for white to invest to
move first
now I thought a knight move I could just
give him a boot but you know what maybe
I am mistaken I think their intention is
to drop the knight in to d6 hmm okay
well what do you do in such a situation
I don't know if I'm so quick to give up
this square hmm all right let's go with
Knight here close to being killed with a
knight move here I don't want to touch
this EEP this C pawn on my next move my
trick my idea Here I am I using trick
all the time I have no tricks my idea is
to play Knight here and then give the
night a kick Knight f5 will control the
square maybe even Knight CA I'm maybe a
bit overexcited about placing my pieces
developing my pieces and then going back
to the 8th ring
but
yeah maybe this is still an idea okay so
they're covering out five it's under
developing but again the position is
closed hmm okay I can't play this just
yet well I'm really uh flirting with
danger here this is this is a bit scary
I must say but I think it'll be all
right um fear I'm already looking at
moves like Bishop here you know and not
pawn takes Queen takes if I block what
the Queen Knight takes here but I'm
Bishop g6 I think I have Queen here at
the very least just defending these two
points and then I'm ready to kick so I'm
under a minute we're about even on time
so let's see if this long term idea here
of one day exchanging the LightSquared
bishop actually takes shape Bishop f4
might be an idea so that the knight can
still look to jump into d6 on c6 let's
see I'd like to see just a developing
move you know quick uh okay well let's
go straight in for this huh what do you
say maybe I could give him a boot I got
one straight in for that huh so this is
some pawn sack I guess I guess that's
what we have we're they missing okay so
they're going with that move well if I
move my knight they're gonna play Bishop
here so let's just recap sure you know
they're playing it as a pawn sack now I
can't take with the bishop because I
drop b7 okay so let's take with the
Queen I guess Bishop f4 is coming so
what if I what if I what have I got
myself into here I am way underdeveloped
for one this is true
and I need to Castle queenside I believe
let's play my queen here my knight is
loose on this square but I'd like to get
them in here however on c3 I don't know
I may meet Bishop f4 with Bishop d6
they're under 20 seconds Bishop f4
Bishop d6 Queen takes here queenside
castle I'm gonna give that a shot
haven't worked it all out wow that was a
very fast move
let's Castle I know I'm dropping this
hmm they could take that okay I think I
really do need to stop
they have Queen takes ecigs I missed
this idea I thought Queen takes I could
take the knight let's go here you're
starting to play very fast let's go here
looking for maybe this advance maybe
challenged the knight get him involved
ooh it's gonna come down to this huh I
missed that move I should not have
allowed this okay mass exchange is
incoming
let's ooh
that's a really strong move yeah that
was a really strong move I'm busted now
let me check
okay yeah this is gone Queen here and
that's it yep I'm gonna resign that one
that was a really good move I totally
missed that one
all righty let me go into the analysis
board hmm I know my development was
backward I was that was that's exactly
what I was signing up for
mm-hmm
this light square bishop exchange it
took much longer to try and get that in
and they ended up jumping into d6 their
night I was up material and you'll see
that from time to time where there's a
little bit of a trade-off where you
could be up material but your opponent
has a lead and development yeah you know
mmm right at that ending when it was
just a heavy piece they were really
quick that a5 move I shouldn't allow
that a5 move I shouldn't have allowed
the opening of the a file that rooks got
to active in when I was having to let me
just show that right at the end this
point right here I cannot allow I was
going to go here and maybe I just should
have this was what my instinct told me
to do but I totally missed that they
could push a5 and you know what I was
thinking I can't do this because if
Queen takes pawn but I'm there to defend
oh okay well I should have done this on
this move because this is a fine
recapture I could think about c4 and
then targeting the b-pawn but okay that
didn't happen did it who want this I do
have some experience with this capture
line focusing on the C 4 square you this
is this is still another approach to go
in for that and get a little bit more
development over here and get the light
square bishop exchange like this but the
computer will not be an agree
with this idea of playing the bishop
back but it is it is a it is an idea and
it's granted very slow and under
developing and it breaks a lot of
principles but this is this is the idea
at least to make this a light square
bishop exchange happen is this is the
long term strategy so we got this in
night here yeah I don't know if I would
deplete it any difference still have to
take care of that d6 square and is there
a way to hurt me even sooner I don't
think so you know if this night was
somehow here that could be a great
bother you know tonight on the rim is
not so bad and maybe this is even an
idea you know - hmm maybe even play
Knight here
yeah Knight to h6 and then maybe f4 to
here maybe even a F pawn advance yeah
but anyhow they went with Knight f3 h6
right around here I mean I think this is
the moment where MMA be the computer is
saying equal ish they're going to give
some weight to the white position due to
this e5 pawn but I'm really close to
getting this this light squared bishop
exchange and I have I have a thing that
I wanted which is a good pawn structure
and a bishop that complements it well
well the cost here is of course time you
know very behind in development Queen
back
Bishop f4 and maybe I should have still
not gotten the two head of myself with
okay now's my moment here too
yeah I think there was a serious error
in my thinking right here couldn't I
come to think of it this I think the
thoughts that was uh I was experiencing
right here was you know what I'm really
behind in development I think I'm going
to play here and give some material back
but this is the only thing I have this
is the only thing I have is just this
one pawn and I'm still going to be
behind in development after this capture
and this is a serious pawn like they
take the Jeep on they have pressure on
the F pawn the H bond so I should still
hold my ground here's what I'm saying I
got a little bit too I was too quick to
give back the material they didn't take
it on the very next move but they took
it one move later what should I have
done maybe even here instead of Bishop
d6 well Queen here and here's another
thing this is something I was thinking
about I wasn't able to voice it at this
stage but I was fearing this rook move
and then some sacrifices here the rook
capture there's pressure on this
structure so Queen here rook here
yeah well I'm able to castle in time I
do get this move in hmm it may still be
even a bit tricky for me to develop like
just making it move like that doing
something like this to play to defend my
pawn and then finally get my bishop
develop that runs into this tactic so it
could still be a bit tricky to complete
development but once it got right around
here I'm definitely the worst side
I have nothing to show for my backward
development I don't know well I don't
know how much worse off maybe maybe I'm
too quick actually to say that yeah I
don't know that I'm so worse off here
yeah I don't know I really don't know
about that right here I know that it's
pretty even once we get into this heavy
piece ending but we'll see what the
suggestions are for the computer by the
computer this was a really strong move
again once it got to the point where I
did allow the a file to open up which
there's no way I could be better now I'm
on the defensive entirely in this Queen
move I believe is just a dagger yeah it
must be computers suggesting King here
that's when you know it's problem
oh it's suggesting King here right now
prior to the removal up on Queen here
yeah it's a problem okay well let's
throw the evaluation on yeah the Queen
there's no defense after Queen here was
there even a defense right around here
now it's plus two okay well let's just
quickly look in the opening it will be
saying that white is just the better
side for a great portion of it you know
it's if it's around this evaluation here
of 0.7 I'm not I'm not so concerned
about that oh wow
c4 oh you got to be kidding me
when is it story with c4 most explosive
move in chess ninety six now it's even
oh oh what is this idea with c4 you
can't just take the knight Canyon chop
I guess my my Kings position is going to
be exposed here now that the center is
opening up moves out of nowhere or
possible huh when you neglect
development
see for ya didn't consider that at all
and I imagine my opponent didn't either
and that's so human-like to play c4 here
when your night is under fire okay they
went right in and they want to just go
straight in for this well I think I
would have played it exactly how I
played at first with capturing on a6 not
having those double pawns
okay so take stakes and now g6o g6 huh
likes white here even though I'm up upon
close to equal but not quite yeah I mean
this is the trade-off hmm once you go
with castles here yeah Castle kingside
make up your mind computer yeah on King
side there's bishop here I guess it's a
problem no matter what if I do this
Bishop takes h6 Knight takes here Knight
takes Queen takes I'm getting made it
even what's the maid exactly oh that's a
nice one for white okay so just going
back some right around here I need to be
need to be accurate takes takes what is
with this h5 move mmm want me to insert
this h5 move oh okay
maybe mmm what am i oh oh and about I do
have in this position maybe though or
one of the things I could be looking for
in this position where after I take
they're not taking back right away they
take here I could be looking for a way
to save mine
from d6 like to f5 or here but none of
these moves right now are throwing a
great punch maybe the idea is that the
Queen can't so easily maintain pressure
on g5 anymore huh if she goes to g6 this
is my moment to play here or here throw
a punch at the Queen and only then
recapture okay so this is another
correction on well this is another
thought process that I could have gone
through at this very moment at this
precise moment where my opponent did not
go with the well they they went with his
in-between move Bishop takes Bishop
instead of the natural meeting a capture
with a recapture so this is a moment to
maybe pause and try and work away work
out a way to maybe make a knight move
work with tempo this would have been a
nice move
h5 Queen here and there's some success
with this move because I don't have the
pressure on g5 I can now take and on
this capture although they're suggesting
Bishop g5 right now but let's just go
straight in for this I can now safely
recapture and develop much much
different scenario here much much
different outcome with these last few
moves more it's a much easier for me to
complete my development okay so this is
still going to cause me some problems I
guess can't Castle queenside so easily
can't play f6 but I was gonna go here
but I guess there's an idea of keeping
this square open for the night yeah this
is a way forward certainly Queen d7
Knight here maybe then even f6 queenside
castle
g5 expand on the against the white king
and always always always for sure being
in and visit any position to me a5 which
b5 it cannot allow that a file to open
up had a blind spot there and those are
not heavy piece specific ending but yeah
that would have been nice right at this
critical moment here so note to self in
those in-betweener
moments yeah maybe
give it a little bit more if I think hmm
h5 would have been a nice a nice move
okay
so this is how played out and one other
thing is right around here I was
thinking of playing rook here and
meeting this with this move and if Queen
takes I take here and in the end result
time of a piece
unfortunately white would have on Bishop
takes Knight Queen takes pawn and that's
a check and they're they're killing me
so went with queenside castle they get
the material back right there Queen back
that's just a slight pull for white here
mm-hmm yes still just a slight pull and
yeah I wanted to go here and it's fine
if they take even prefers black now
because my rooks will be the one to put
pressure on the white pawn structure and
black as a result will have to go on the
defense of some yeah
a5 I have to play b5 this is just no
good I had a blind spot here thinking if
I push that the Queen could take here
and then they followed up nicely simply
doubling and
and I'm busted from here mmm okay well I
think I would have certainly revisit
this idea in a future game and it's nice
to be aware of these uh little nuances
in the position as things heat up when
they're those in between moves and such
but yeah anyhow as usual feel free to
leave any feedback to this video in the
comment section below
and as usual I hope you got something
out of it that's all for now take care
bye